David, I know you think Trump won't be arrested,
but will he be investigated when he leaves office?
So almost certainly there are going
to be investigations of Donald Trump's
businesses. There's going to be a lot of financial
crime investigation. It's possible that even
people close to Donald Trump are going
to go down. But, yeah, I still don't
think you're ever going to see Trump in prison.
There are a lot of people who rightly are feeling
that if Donald Trump isn't personally prosecuted,
that an injustice has been done. And I am not
arguing that Trump has done nothing worthy of
being investigated and potentially charged with
criminality. But this is not a country that does
that. And I know that that upsets lots of people.
And some people like the fact that this is not a
country that every time you get a new president,
they investigate charge and potentially even in
prison the previous president. It's not a country
that does that. I don't think we're
going to see that. What we will see
are investigations into Donald Trump's business
dealings and financial stuff. I think that
Trump's enablers can and should be prosecuted
directly when it applies. This includes family.
This includes Republican senators. This includes
other functionaries, people involved in enabling.
Illegal activity, even if it's financially
illegal activity, if such activity exists,
they should be harshly penalized. As far
as Trump goes, I don't think it'll touch
Trump. I think there's the real possibility
that his businesses will end up having to
settle and pay absolutely massive fines. It's
conceivable that if you find people involved
in Trump's businesses caught red handed with
financial fraud, money laundering, whatever,
it's possible they may end up convicted. I
just don't think it's going to touch Trump
and I don't think it's going to be for political
crimes. It'll be a tax evasion, money laundering,
improper use of charities, which Donald
Trump has already been been caught doing.
I think it will be that type of thing. I do
believe that Trump is worried because Trump
doesn't know. We had a few reports from right
before the election that part of why Trump is
panicking is because he's worried that the rest
of his life will be riddled by investigations
and maybe he could end up in prison.
I just don't think he'll end up in
prison. I think it's completely plausible that
you do see investigations of different kinds
plague the rest of Donald Trump's life. Now,
on the other side, there's people asking about
pardons. Couldn't Trump preemptively pardon
everybody who's likely to be wrapped up in this?
You know, I think there's two things that
will prevent that from happening. No.
One, I don't think Trump really cares about these
people. Trump doesn't care about his supporters.
It's not clear Trump even cares about
his enablers. And that's one part of
it. The other part of this is Trump has not
shown himself to be detail oriented enough
to actually figure out who is it that I need to
grant blanket preemptive pardons for. So I don't
think that Trump will do it. He may do it with
some. I don't think he will get to everybody. And
then the other reason I think you are going to see
a deluge of investigations and possible charges
after Trump is out of office when it comes to his
associates is look at how many Trump associates
were convicted while Donald Trump was in office
with the Department of Justice encumbered by
Trump loyalists, running interference. Once
Trump is gone and you have a different Justice
Department, I think you will see many more Trump
acolytes go down. Now, the last thing I want to
say about this, Joe Biden shouldn't be involved
in this at all. Remember when Trump was saying
to Hillary during the twenty sixteen debates, if I
was president, you'd be locked up and we're going
to investigate you and all of this stuff.
And in fact, while Trump was president,
he tried to push the Justice Department.
Can't you investigate Biden? Can't you
do this? Can't you do that? Joe Biden should
have no involvement whatsoever in any possible
investigations of anybody associated with
Donald Trump. I don't believe Joe Biden will
do that. Joe Biden has shown no interest in
that. He's shown no willingness to do that.
And to be perfectly frank, even if he liked the
idea of being involved in investigations of Trump,
Joe Biden's going to have his hands more than full
trying to clean up the mess from from from Donald
Trump. And he will be plenty busy. And I believe
that the next Department of Justice will also be
very, very busy. Look at what escaped the Trump
bubble while he was president that we learned
about in terms of criminality. Imagine what we're
going to learn about once he's finally gone.